and the latest episode of the voices of
the nfl series here on just getting
started i could not be more thrilled to
have this man on the show because um
i
quite frankly can't do anything about
the voices of the nfl without the voice
of the nfl at the worldwide leader in
sports and certainly the voice of the
nfl in terms of calling highlights as
this man has done for so many years and
still does on nfl
um nfl prime time uh and i just love
this guy be able to thrill to be able to
have him here call him a friend
colleague he's chris berman how are you
boom good to see you hi rich always a
pleasure to be with you we were
colleagues many many moons ago
uh you've gone on to great things and
you work too hard but i'm glad you could
squeeze me in palace it was a pleasure
to see you and best of your fam we
missed i miss you too man so let's just
jump right into this because i am so
fascinated i've never really
have been able to sit down with you and
ask you these questions and you know
obviously when i first got to espn um in
96 i always wanted to ask you these
questions never really had the
opportunity to but
how did you get started chris berman in
your career how did it all start
i hope it wasn't too menacing for you to
uh to ask those
no it's quite the contrary chris you
were always available but i just didn't
want to you know i mean
you you're running around you had a lot
going on and um well we all did that was
the beauty of the place even when you
were here at the start it still is but
you know 80s and 90s i mean i digress
for a minute we
we all had a ton to do and so
we all got along great and still do um
but it was
as you know we were it was two people
doing the job of six etcetera etcetera
as you've experienced at the nfl network
at any rate
so went to brown
um major in american history
um
brown
we have to take ourselves way back and
not back back back to not being trite
but you know late 60s early 70s
you had college radio stations you had
newspapers that's really what you had
and wbru was a 50 000 watt station in
providence rhode island like it was a
real
station you know and
brown was also a great school and and so
i fooled him and i got in and got went
right up to the radio and got involved
and eventually became the sports
director etc became the voice of the
bruins and did what you would do at
college i mean it brown football brown
basketball and even brown baseball even
though the only people couldn't hear me
were the people actually in the dugouts
but um
but it was experience right
so i'll be quick to get to espn i first
job was in westerly rhode island great
beach town um
however i started uh you know
right after graduation i worked every
year they were great
i
didn't do sports i mean a little radio
station i did
i was a disc jockey i did
uh the
news talk shows i
you know the the one minute when you
were reading the five minute news
that i got to read sports was like a
highlight you know uh i did play how
deep is your love by the bee gees like
every hour for six months
i mean you know so
when i hear that song i i smile but it's
like oh my god it's a great song but oh
my god at any rate um
uh it was platinum only by me i mean i
played it that often so um
uh then i went to a radio station
uh 14 nvr in waterbury connecticut so a
little bit bigger city of uh you know
old new england town of about a hundred
hundred
thirty thousand among other things today
unheard of then
a sports talk show now they're all over
obviously but in 1978 79 rich
and that you'll know who i did it with
that bob sagandorf has it that's who it
was and um
um
there was one in the state of
connecticut guy named arnold dean and we
were on for 90 minutes monday to friday
and he was yankees i was red sox he was
new york giants i was jets and patriots
afl
et cetera et cetera et cetera uh
you know and
so made for natural good
iterate sports talk among other things
then i was fortunate enough to get on
the nbc station in hartford um
they
it was a uhf station channel 30 nbc
affiliate but the weekend sports guy was
just saturday sunday showed up then for
three dollars a show
twenty seventy nine hours
you you heard me after a minimum pound
um
and
so every three or six months if somebody
was good they would move on to a
full-time deal and
they looked at my tape the news director
at arnold klinske told me when i applied
once before you're the second best one
yeah right well that guy left after
three months and he called me and goes
can you come in to make another one i
did so i got on
weekend sports in the summer of 79
which was when espn was about to start
september 7th 1979.
i applied and rather than send them a
tape i said just watch i mean it's going
to be pretty raw but watch it and
they looked
they offered me a job uh which i started
october 1st
so one month in
um
at the 2 30 or then the 3 a.m sports
center
which it was midnight on the west coast
but
you're driving home in the snow at four
in the morning you know your parents
thought really like you're doing this
but
i primarily did that but hosted our nfl
uh
show which was not countdown or game day
at the time but
look
so i've spent a little time saying it
but this is now 42 years ago
it was my first opportunity to be on tv
every day
uh we didn't know who was watching maybe
we're in three million homes then in
1979 80. but
you're doing a
what it's become our profession you're
doing sports on tv and a lot of football
every night
for a half hour or more
and
you couldn't get that experience at a
local station rich you know you get
three minutes at six and eleven you know
what i'm saying and they're
we and we have to bring it i'm going on
because i want to bring it to your list
no no no i i i'm fascinated by all of
this but i just want to just
go back a little bit here
so you're saying
you were you know you got a gig in
waterbury and thus that got you to
hartford and that anybody who doesn't
know those are basically the two largest
municipalities surrounding bristol
connecticut
uh on the west and the east so you're
kind of circling around bristol there
and and you found out that there was
this startup
for 24 7 sports and you love sports and
so you you
put something in and basically
said hey get out your rabbit ears and
watch
you know live local late breaking i'm on
and that's how they discovered you
that's how they they essentially found
you
that kind of um
i think they
were looking for anybody that wouldn't
embarrass them
because my obviously my tv track record
was three months
so that's uh that would be in horse
racing terms of maiden race right
so um
and
but there i was
on the late show the first year pretty
much by myself but then with tommy means
a lot the god rest his soul and and uh
and
lo and behold
i got okay at it uh lo and behold
in 1980 or 81 espn was in six million
homes or whatever the number was and and
you know the rest of the espn story i
don't need to tell it um
but so i was 24
with a kind of a not a fool but a kind
of a late 70s ron burgundy
um
and uh
hey they worked in the day okay and uh
and hair pretty good
well ridiculous but
it's late 70s and um
i was on tv and
i was here when there were about 75 of
us rich 75 today and
everybody knew everybody's name and
to have a hand in the cornerstone of
i'm not more important than anyone else
and anyone else that worked in the early
80s to help put this thing
on the map for good but you know
because i was on the air more people
know me and the fact that i'm still here
from 24 now i'm 66
come on now that's a story disney world
it is it is amazing it truly is when was
the first time
chris where you realized this this is
working like okay
this is
coming together and
and you're on
you're on your way
when did that first kind of hit you was
there a moment a show or
a conversation or anything like that
it's a good question it would be i don't
want to say gradually it would be in
increments it's different than gradually
i remember
uh kathy and i were my late wife kathy
and i weren't married yet but we took a
west coast vacation 81-ish
or maybe
and before the football season because
then i knew um
and
going to restaurant again west coast so
that's who would really be watching we
our show wasn't even on in a rear in the
morning yet
and nice you know sat down somewhere and
then
does the swami want to see the wine list
and i went what you know so you start to
get these these inclinations that maybe
there's some people
like the moody blues saying i know
you're out there somewhere right
letters from uh
from the midwest uh fathers changing
their babies diapers and i went why
would they do that at two in the morning
like what's the matter with them you
know
then you become a father and you get it
obviously um
but i'll give you a funny
well all right there are couple one you
won't be that surprised on what is it
really interesting story about espn and
how i knew
again
as the each year goes on you're
recognized in this etc
and the players start to know you
and they want to do interviews with you
because honestly their mom and dad in
mississippi might see it
even though they're playing in
washington dc for the re for the then
redskins right
i remember one in particular so jerome
barker because my mom and dad will see
this of course i'll do it you know
and
you
reel back a little so 81
the swami predicted the 49ers a lot like
every week and they were not very good
the year before and we all know what
happened and that was the beginning of
everything
i went out to cover the game which
eventually became with the catch
in which one of the most famous in nfl
history and
in my beginning years of espn there's
nothing bigger
we went to interview the 49ers on
friday and charlie young the veteran
tight end and randy cross not veteran
veteran but you had been there a while
lineman a couple of us lined up the
players and they went
you're the swami you've been picking us
every week
we have as much time as you need like
really
and then the catch and this and of
course
joe and dwight latoya clark joe montana
and the whole team coach walsh i mean
they let me in and eddie debartolo the
owner and we could go on and on and on
and i was i was their age
but they were watching
all right now i'm going to give you a
story you're really going to laugh about
it because you're not expecting to hear
this not about me
the network story 1983
the america's cup stalling okay
sale
um
this was the one off newport which they
all were just about all were then 83
that the us eventually lost in the
seventh race to australia with the
winged keel i know i'm really going back
it was a tuesday you know at four
o'clock three o'clock
a providence
tv station i want to say wjar i'm not
sure had a
helicopter
hovering over the race and they were
broadcasting it throughout rhode island
we tapped into that feed
and showed it without any hey we're
gonna have the america's cup it was just
on okay at three o'clock in the
afternoon on a tuesday
match race seven
and it rained back then people thinking
well jesus
would a sailboat race beyond who knows
how many sailboat racing fans there were
in 1983
they tried us be like a big news event
but you're going to cnn about in the 80s
they're it right
we got a two point something
on an unannounced
sailboat race admittedly the biggest one
and historic
and
it was a okay
people are looking to us if something
happens in sports taking a shot
and if we give it to them whether it's
sportscenter or whatever else
they're going to be with us i mean so
that was uh
you weren't expecting that story but
i'll never forget that you got to be
kidding me well i mean i i remember one
again when i got there in 96 and i was
learning about the history of the place
and
and how you know the americas cup and
dennis connor and all of that stuff was
very big
in the
ascension and the growth of espn as as
as a spot where
you know you might not find the
traditional four american sport you know
if you're looking for something outside
of the traditional four american north
american sports you can find it and then
obviously sports center became a place
for you to go
and watch stuff and seeing you there and
the rest of the crew that was there at
the time
it was something for me
certainly when i got to college in 1986
this is what i wanted to do i knew i
knew it on the spot like this is
for somebody i grew up in new york i was
a marv albert guy i was a howard coselle
guy uh a jerry gerard guy if that name
rings a bell to you from channel 11 wpix
in new york he was kind of doing some
sportscenter stuff locally i
i did stand up in college and i'm like
this is it
and
part of that was also
borne out of watching you
not just on sportscenter but doing the
draft
and doing the nfl draft
and i'm wondering
when did
espn truly show up on the nfl's radar
screen as a viable
partner
for well the draft was
and you know the back story that chet
simmons then our president told pete
rose that we'd like to televise the
draft and he asked why
um
but
we did um
so the draft was watched by as i quickly
found out because i'm calling the gms
etc for information which
you could get if you knew how to do it
and you knew how to protect it etc etc
etc because not many people were doing
it and
so rich i knew that the football people
were watching okay
so
at least for the draft
now
until
game day which of course now is
countdown started in 85 we did another
little nfl show but
but
we knew they were watching
um
i remember the cowboys went out of their
way in a game i went to in the early 80s
to make tech shram available for me
little chris berman on the 50-yard line
before a game at san francisco not the
catch but a couple years later i think
it was a monday night or other you know
etc and
so they knew
i started myself started going to nfl
owners meeting could have been 84
and
you know when art rooney
the the
art rooney senior
comes over and extends his hand and
introduces himself
hey you're for the sports people your
network we're really not to mention al
davis who i'd met earlier but not only
about me but i'm the i'm a conduit at
that point at this meetings
and
so you knew they knew
and although we didn't tip his hand pete
roselle obviously knew because
and for him to take a chance
in the league
for him to take a chance at 1987
adding
a sunday night game the last
it was after the world series was over
so is the last what eight weeks of the
season starting halloween ish
and be available on the let's and the
first game was uh was the patriots in
the jet and the giants i think so
uh it was on a local station in each of
the markets who might not be getting
cable
but to put a sunday night game eight
weeks a year i mean they repeat congress
you can't do it it's got to be it's a
for him to take a chance
i don't know if you met pete i'm sure
you i mean got to know him well i'm sure
you did i did um
i was honored that he for whatever
reason liked me
and um
for him to have the vision representing
the league
in 87 to make that a
a brave new television world other than
just the afc network the nfc network and
monday night football and then we're
going to have eight games on cable and
we're going to get this show called nfl
primetime which was steve bornstein who
was not our president yet but as you
well know our programming guru and way
up there and going to be president a
couple years later and he and pete
rozelle thought that up as part of the
deal
and we're going to do a show that no
one's seen because nobody
as you know as everybody knows you saw
three games well seattle's playing
arizona it was 45-42 nobody saw any of
that here you go here's five minutes or
whatever and
there was not a big part well it was a
as history goes
so i give so you
p roselle didn't just wake up in april
of or whatever it was in 87 to decide ah
let's go with cable
in retrospect we knew they were paying
attention for two or three years it's
really
an amazing story and it's something that
people shouldn't take for granted
because you know everything that's done
that winds up being
a smash hit i think in our business
initially starts as a risk
that is ultimately a calculated one you
know and
i i really believe that
chris you know i've been saying that for
a long time and you know
i remember
when bernstein you know
hired me to
to be the first guy at nfl network
and then
put us at radio city for the draft
um and i was across the way from you
you know in the same mezzanine
and i think you might have been the one
to say it was like that uh
looney tunes cartoon where you know the
dog and the glue and wiley coyote are
punching in the clock at the same
you know
at the same spot and then going to their
different ways and obviously competing
but
you know it was it was huge for me uh it
still is it still is because of you know
the stage that you set and the standard
that you set
and and how
remarkable it is is just it's
it's the off-season super bowl there's
just no other way to put it
chris there's no no other way bro you
know
well i don't know what i said are there
a lot of people as you know that the
people's names they'll never know that
we're as as instrumental if not more so
than me and those on the air and mel i
mean we could go down the list but it
was
look at how the draft has grown every
couple of years it's unbelievable from
little sheraton or wherever it was
we were reading the manhattan phone book
in the early 80s
to
then the marriott marquis like that
became okay like this is
something and then we had 200 people up
there right like oh and you know a
couple dressed as a
new orleans saint there's one dress
that's you know one
cowboy hat etc etc and it was
and then to other places in new york and
then radio city
when we hit radio city and you brought
that up then it was
so wait a minute now
you know my folks grew up in new york
like they
told me all the shows they'd seen there
you know frank sinatra ella fitzgerald i
mean do we i mean we could go on and on
and on i don't want to bore everybody
but all the you know all the the uh the
big band sounds and etc and uh louis
armstrong i mean
and yet here's rich eisen later on and
here's chris berman at radio city
what's wrong with this sentence frank
sinatra
chris blarman rich eisen
which two of these do not belong right
the old
thing
but it was really cool then of course
it's going on leaps and bounds beyond it
and it's it's become a spectacle um but
still how you build a football team when
you get right down to it it is and
everybody's o and o and everybody thinks
everybody's been drafted as the next
great
it's all good so um
so chris let me
what do you think makes the nfl work i
mean you've been you've been there and
done that and you have launched
shows and launched obvious as we just
discussed with the draft
um uh tent polls
of of the annual
calendar that we all um
we all now take for granted so
what is your
it's one of the greatest narrative
generating machines in the history of
anything but what what do you think
makes the nfl work
in a manner that you have been uh you
know a voice of their
of the league and the the sports
popularity and ascendancy for the last
40 years what do you think about that
well i think it's a and that's a good
question
um
i was young obviously when it in the 60s
television would be your first kind of
answer although that's not uh
we're taking it to today i mean that's
not to put what
mr halas and jim thorpe and and you know
red grains etc etc i know the history of
it you know the history of it and i'm we
are forever
fortunate that they me making nothing
playing it for whatever
that got to the 60s and then
here's tv
and it was a tv sport
you know you could sit and watch and
there's the field and there are the
colors in there and it's on a sunday i'm
going back
you know it's
it's a gathering point
i think
so it's a long answer i don't want to be
that way
um you know the citrus is a long time
ago but that's when tv kind of exploded
and that's when football started to
explode and then
you know i did it it surpassed baseball
and there's no it's not like a race like
a like a nascar race where i'm what lap
did it but
um
i think
part of it is
each game means a lot and i i think if
you get to the bottom of it
each game means a lot there's only 16 or
in this case 17 and there used to be 12
and then 14 and 16 but
you play once a week and you blow one or
two of them and you've changed you've
altered your team's run so that's part
of the allure
as a fan
um
i used to explain people i thought
you could go around you can be fanatic
obviously but you can go around your
your weekly life
you got to like wednesday morning to die
to digest what happened on let's just
keep it at sunday for now for simplicity
sunday or even monday night whatever um
what your team did
you might have to go to work early
monday morning you got a couple days to
really delve into now i've read more
about it and i've heard more about it
it's tuesday and how did they run this
and why did this work it's a
and now starting about wednesday rich
it's anticipation
right
it's not
the baseball one of the beauties of it
is it's every day
but part of football is
oh we're gonna play
this you know the so-and-so's and we
don't like them and they beat us the
last three times and we're good enough
this time and it's wednesday evening and
you're starting to get ready for that
game as a fan talk about as a fan
and so
anticipation i think is is a big part of
it maybe overlooked uh i think you agree
and then
now sunday comes that it's christmas
every sunday right and
um
so it's a
that's just from a fans perspective i
don't mean this you're deep into this
that
and the experience of still going to a
game if you're lucky enough to do that
or
you're in remote areas and you wouldn't
miss a game of
the chicago bears i mean whatever
and you can see them and it's
and there's something special about
each game meaning something
the season lasts for argument's sake
four months
not including the playoffs
and it it starts to go through and you
can't go in a lot of the country outside
and do things like you'd like to do in
the summer i mean you're in l.a it's a
different story but you know what i mean
and i mean football was born in those
other areas where
other than going to a stadium and a coat
or whatever we're not doing a lot of
stuff outside unless we're skating on a
pond so
i think
it's still special
i think it's and of course the unknown
i mean
we can boil down why the game is so
predictable to one thing rich
the ball is not round
yeah so and that's why they play the
games as somebody wants why they play
the games i love that so uh
in in bringing this uh somewhat full
circle in a way one last question about
your gigs and then just to wrap up the
whole conversation about your career and
and the best advice you've gotten which
is what i've been asking everybody
in this podcast series but
the pro football hall of fame and being
the emcee for the big day for the
enshrinement day
um what's your favorite give me a good
story your favorite story what involves
a hall of famer
whether it's you know jim kelly creating
that bar that's off to the side because
he wants to make sure the long day goes
a little quicker
i don't know and anything anybody you've
met from over those years
um
that you'd that you can share with
somebody about
being the mc in canton year in and year
out well first of all as you know
because you emcee that the the gold
jacket dinner is so beautifully it it's
an honor just to be in our roles right
like we'll start with that right i speak
for you i know that you talked about it
many clues
um i've been lucky enough to do that for
[Music]
20 years or 22 years whatever it is um
and if they ask i'll do it every year um
they can wheel me up there and i'll do
it um
hearing
off to the sides as you know and our
your viewers know um
all the hall of famers are up there so
there's stories i can go way back
but i'm just going to go back three or
four years
jim brown doesn't make it every year
he's okay come some
but every running back this is during
one of the commercial breaks so it
wasn't really seen on tv and i have the
picture on my phone i'm not in it don't
get me wrong um
every running back who's up there
from emmett
to there might have been like 12 of them
only the running backs gathered around
the big kind of chair the gym is in this
on the stage
everybody handed their camera to
somebody taking the picture their phone
and they were
didn't matter that emmett had the most
yards or
uh i i think this was a year that a lot
of them came you know i'm going through
the great names i mean walter of course
passed barry you know i don't know that
barry might have been there sanders
franco yeah i'm sure franco and marshall
yeah
of course
leroy kelly was there i mean i'm gonna
miss a ton
they all got in the picture with jim
brown it's like they were kids
i got them on jim brown's team
you know and to this day
i know our youngsters don't
i i have a hard time putting anybody
ahead of him as the greatest football
player of all time i mean we can debate
it and that's what's fun but i mean what
tom brady's done and and you know jerry
rice has done and i mean we joe montana
but
jim brown is like that's it whoa that's
it it's like saying that's marty right
like
and a couple others and so
i remember that
it's fun personally for me to
give the this this speech speech
minute minute and a half but i try to
throw in something especially the guys
that the guy's going in now for a long
time we've covered from you know their
whole career
yeah pretty far but i got to be such
great friends and still are through the
years that um
but to tell a little story in my little
intro before we go to the tape
and then brett or whoever gets up there
and speaks
and to look back at them over there and
i remember in brett's case she was off
to the side and i went you know where
i'm going here brett you know and he
starts laughing like a little kid and i
told the story of but that that's more
of a personal the jim kelly
so jim kelly you mentioned him was the
first year that we ever had it in the
stadium too many people came to me he's
so popular from right buffalo and
pittsburgh and
you could draw a line from buffalo to
pittsburgh right to canton they all just
yeah they all just came right there from
that they could come that day rich or
some of them drove their campers there
on thursday right like it's
and i walked out just to tap the mic
like 20 minutes before the whole thing
started
so jim went in when in o2 i mean i'm i'm
doing the may return 96. it would 00102
but you get the point right um
and i just tapped the mic and being a
little bit identified with buffalo
the place started going nuts i went
oh
this is a buffalo home game i get it it
was in the afternoon then um
one more that i'll tell you it used to
be on the steps of the hall i'm going
back a long way
and
when a steeler went in and they went in
one or two every year
pittsburgh is even closer to buffalo
right to canton
there was no room there on the steps of
the hole at noon by the way it was hot
okay all the time hot
uh
this blazer would have been a darker
blue by that time if if we were going
back to those days of being able to
sweat it through it but um
there are people hanging off the
interstate
you know when terry bradshaw would go in
and or i mean name your steeler and uh
franco i mean just name them and
and and i i want to say a steeler went
out i could be wrong when joe montana
and ronnie lot they went in together
along with it was
on the stairs
people hanging off the interstate
the energy
and that's when the hall said yeah we
want to think about a statement
and and then that changed that i mean
there's so many individual stories and
you're around the players too but they
they
chiefs and raiders from the afl sitting
together and laugh i love it
hello
that did not happen back in the day okay
well
i'll tell you this story um from my
first year at the hall when i had just
you know left espn or parted ways
however you want to put it and
and the first assignment for nfl network
was to go to the hall
that summer of 2003 and i'd never been
i'd covered cooperstown before and
cooperstown is like um
you know like a rockwell painting you
know it's it's there's one stoplight and
it the the the golden light when the sun
sets right
and the pro football hall of fame is as
you point out by i-77 it's football
there's an interstate there's trucks
going by there's like the the figurines
that look like the thing from the
fantastic four on the side of the
building you know the juicer you know it
was it's just totally different from
cooperstown and experience as you can
possibly get and it was kind of jarring
for me to see that
um and so
we sat down with a bunch of hall of
famers to record some stuff
that we wound up putting in the can to
use
the next year
when i was still employee only number
one
and we we needed to put stuff on the air
as programming when we flew out to ohio
to do the event so it was filler
programming that we were shooting a year
before
so i'm telling the story because again
it involves jim brown to bring this all
full circle
and and the the immense
respect
that everybody who's in that building
has for jim brown okay
and that i sat down with ronnie lott and
merlin olsen and asked them about the
toughest
biggest hit they ever delivered on
anybody and merlin olson said the
biggest hit he ever delivered i can't
i'm so excited to be telling you this
story the the the biggest hit he'd ever
delivered on anybody
was jim brown
that the browns came to the la coliseum
and all of them the whole you know four
horsemen were saying all week we're
gonna kill him
you know you never got a good shot on
this guy ever he was like you never got
a good shot on jim brown and here he was
coming around the end and merlin had him
he had him and he blew him up and merlin
olson said he hit him so hard he had
visions of when he got up seeing jim's
eyes rolling in the back of his head and
when merlin olson got up he said he
watched jim brown go another 70 yards
for the touchdown
it's one of my favorite stories
i've ever heard
that that's that's it so
that's it one when they had the
sh must have been rich the
75th oh no that was it that was the
three
it was the 50th anniversary it was the
50th anniversary that that the first
year that i was there and everyone was
there it was like literally a night at
the museum the busts came alive that
time yes i was there for that unreal and
and i was the emcee early and it was
noon
we didn't know what order there would
have been joe horrigan who was the
greatest is the greatest uh you know the
hall the curator forever and ever and
ever
they would come out
no i recognized there were a hundred of
them and i
i know a lot of them but i'm also facing
the crowd and i'm looking and who
and so
we have no idea it's when they get off
the bus
and i think the first three
were like
icons
um i don't know if merlin was one but
roger staubach was one
uh gail sayers was one
and
i it was another mural it could have
been like a bob lilly or you know a
you knew who it was it was an icon
and
and then there was nobody and i had the
car but i looked at the crowd and
they're going after ryder starback gayle
sayers
i don't think it was joe yet namath
might have been
i went how are we doing so far you know
because that that they said not they had
not had that that anniversary yet and
otto graham came out you know i mean we
could go on and on and on and and uh
i had known him a little you know this
is otto graham now you know before my
time
and
although i met him when he was athletic
director at the coast guard but uh
there's a little interesting one but um
and he leaned into my ear and cracked me
up like this is rough tough autograph
and he said something that was it was
you know
the lead the busts came alive
i mean and we still have that to this
day
when when they come back and a big
player goes in um
and
it's with reverence the day is with
reverence and i hope that the fans at
home though do watch it it's really the
beginning of the season i know there's a
game that's now before it i get it
but when you see the legends come back
um and others who have passed away were
talk about them
okay it's august 6th or whatever it is
and here's football
here's football for the next six months
have a good yeah the other the other
sports either hold it in
the off season or in the middle of the
season the nfl holds it at the outset of
a season celebrating the past
remembering the past honoring the past
and then celebrating the fact that it's
a return it's
there's nothing like it
uh i i know we've been going on and on i
don't want to take up much more your
time but to finish up i will ask you the
question i've asked everybody that's uh
that's done this part and kind enough to
do this part what's the best piece of
advice you've gotten in your career
for you
and by whom
chris what would that be well no no
i mean we've gotten a lot of it
and we needed it
um
part of is
be yourself especially when you're on
every day
because
if you're just and i'm not saying that
people are just on on sundays could be
another person
but if you're on every day
and you're not exactly who you are
whether it's a style somebody we would
prefer to get their sports and our cases
rich
or not um
they can see that you're acting
[Music]
don't be an actor or an actress
be yourself
because if that's not good enough
you can't top that no matter what you
you you try to do when you're on on a
daily basis
um another a lot came from our very
early guys chet simmons and scottie
connell
um who were
old and old they were nbc sports the
honchos they ran it and then they came
over here and they were here at the very
beginning and nurtured us a lot
and
i remember
they're two little things um
and i'll go back to both of them scotty
was more
you you have your your idols or the
people that you look look up to in our
business i said sure i do and you could
rattle off the names kurt gowdy ray
scott jack whitaker and we can go on and
on right
and they go
it's okay scotty said to take a little
piece of of of them you're not stealing
you're
anyone that says here's a unique style
no
if you take a little and you take a
little and then you see some others who
you might even like and
but that's not for me so don't do that
and now you mix it like a chef
and it becomes you
right it becomes you
little of this little of this little is
not that not that and then
bigger part yourself
that becomes you and grow it
all right that's one this is a really
interesting one it's not the
it's a different thing but it it so
my first year here i had a mustache okay
now 79.80 you know sports that
mean i said it was of the time
and chet simmons was our president and
he'd seen me every now and then and
he'd say still got that mustache huh
like didn't say shave it you got to get
rid of it you
know and
about the third time he said it months
apart
still got the mustache now chris i want
chad
i mean is there a problem because
no one said it's a problem
he said i want you to consider something
you pride yourself on content don't you
like on what you say you want people to
listen to what you say right
so if 20 of the people are fixated on
the mustache for whatever reason maybe
they like it or not but they're not
listening to you
you run yourself at this service
not the network yourself
it's like wearing it over the top and we
all do it a tie every now and then but
they're like 10 are looking at it
if you value the content of what you're
saying
um
then you're then you don't want that on
i said it'll be awesome i was about to
say how fast did you how fast did you
you know
it'll be i mean i was now it's at night
so i didn't didn't regularly bring my
razor to work right and uh there was
that now you know the um
i'll morph into something else
somebody might have told me that
but um
but it would be what i would give to
others
is
if it's interesting to you
it's going to be interesting to somebody
else
so let them in on what really interests
you about a game a person a thing you're
covering
some of it can be very heavy news i mean
interesting doesn't have to be fun and
games it can be
very bad news
but whatever put your antenna up
you're not alone
give them that
give them what's interesting to you two
things
and then we'll wrap it up with this two
responses to that one we had kevin
harlan who calls the games of westwood
one and his dad bar bob is the
you know grand poobah for all those
years in in green bay we had him on he
said larry king gave him that same
advice
talk about what interests you is what he
said
that it's amazing that you you heard the
same thing and the other thing is i am
thrilled to be able to
tell you this
this is amazing
life is amazing when i got to espn chris
you did sportscenter like
three four times a year basically like
you you would pop in
right then because i was doing baseball
yeah doing all sorts of stuff but you
would you would return to your sports
center roots
okay
and i was fortunate to be on the
schedule
for one of those
um shows when i first got there
i was on the schedule to observe okay
they wouldn't this was before espn news
where they would throw you on there like
i was thrown into the deep end of the
sportscenter pool as soon as i got there
at age 26 from redding california but i
had to observe okay
so i was in my observation period and
you
were doing a sports center you won't
remember it i was sitting in a corner or
whatever but i was
taking as many mental notes as i
possibly could
and your
advice that you said to be yourself
you walked in the room
of the meeting
and the guy that i saw on television and
the guy that i thought i knew from
television was the guy who walked in the
room
and i swear to god chris that i i'm like
oh my gosh
like the guy who is on tv this is the
guy who's here right now and you were
yourself and i made a mental note of
never put on a voice or just sit there
and try like i have to be true to myself
now that was a a problem when i first
started where i was a little probably
too much of myself and too joking and
not enough to pull back unless it's more
and all that stuff
but your advice that you say be yourself
i took from
from you based on your actions
not you giving me that advice directly
and i'm thrilled to be able to close
this conversation with that and that's a
fact
you know that's a fact chris so well
that thank you well here's the thing
rich
none of us are
are smart enough
to be anyone else
so if all else fails you might as well
be yourself right
i love it chris you're the best man
you're the best and it almost fails like
i tell all the analysts that i work with
over the years
if all else fails
you know when things happen live tv
radio whatever
just talk about football that's it
we're going to fail
right you're the best chris berman
thanks for doing this here on just
getting started thanks brother
uh thanks rich nice to see you i'm proud
of what you've done with your career and
uh um it's nice to see a brethren one of
my one of our brethren do so well the
one and only chris berman uh i i will
tell you this
about him well i got a couple stories to
wrap up this show
with berman with chris
um one thing that we didn't touch on
is that he
chris berman
went to the same high school as keith
olbermann together
he and keith have known each other since
high school
true story fact
and
i remember
uh
because i i i connected with keith first
up
that um i connected with him
because
he
and i shared an agent when we got to
espn the story that i told earlier on
this podcast when joe buck was on
about almost going to st louis
for a job and then espn hired me when i
was
either being considered for or i was
considering i don't know if i was going
to be hired by that
station in st louis out of my
um my station in redding that i was been
telling you about throughout this show
but at any rate
um
keith and i shared an agent an agent
that i met through keith
because
um
i had uh
uh
been an intern at the cbs evening news
in the summer of oj in 1994
and the
guy who ran
cbs evening news new keith and i'll tell
that story at another time but at any
rate keith and i had shared an agent
so
i
was
always asking keith for advice and
things like that and on another episode
i'll tell you about
how sometimes it was tough to get the
advice
but i did ask keith at one point you
know about approaching chris berman
because anybody who's anybody in this
business
in the 90s
ripped off berman i mean there's there's
no question about it i mean keith's
nickname chris's nicknames i mean i
didn't you know what let me just let me
start from scratch here screw everything
i don't like where i've gone with this
here we go in three two the one and only
chris berman let me tell you a couple
stories about
um
chris
and being around chris
as an impressionable 26 year old
sportscenter anchor coming out of
essentially nowhere as i've told on the
story on a previous pod with jim nance
about
my audition and how i got the job there
and how overwhelmed i was to go from a
small market tv station in reading to
espn and now suddenly boom you're a
colleague of chris berman's and anybody
will tell you
and they're lying if they're not
telling you this
in the 80s and 90s anybody who wanted to
be a sportscaster
flocked to chris berman just his
nicknames which we didn't bring up with
chris but just his style his energy
and what he made espn into
uh as something fun sports casting and
fun that's something that spoke to me
and
um also the broadcasting style of keith
olbermann spoke to me as well so when i
got to espn
i you know kind of
flocked to both of them or wanted to
flock towards chris but i didn't know
him at all keith i did
and i'll tell that story on another
episode
but uh the reason why i knew him before
but just to
make this a shortcut here
is keith and i shared an agent the agent
who got
my contract hammered out for my first
deal when i got struck by lightning
figuratively
uh and getting the job at espn from a
small market station in redding
california
i had the same agent as keith so i would
pick his brain i felt comfortable
picking his brain and
sometimes the advice i got was tough
love and very difficult to take and i'll
i'll tell that on a future pod as well
but um when mike taurico's on i'll tell
that story that'll work out
but at any rate
i asked keith about chris because
unbeknownst to a lot of people
keith has known chris since high school
they went to the same high school
together
isn't that crazy
but
so i asked keith about
approaching chris berman because i
wanted to
know
more from him as i just told chris in
this podcast
when he walked into the meeting room
when i was just observing fresh off of
being hired before i was put on my first
sports center
and i'm sitting there and observing and
the guy who walked in the room
was the same guy i'm i knew from
television
and that's important for anybody out
there who's
wants to be successful in this business
you have to be yourself you're your own
fingerprint
and
you know
seeing
chris be the guy in the room that i saw
on tv wanted me to ask him more
questions and tips but again i mean
i was new there and i was difficult to
approach him so i asked keith about
approaching him and he said just go up
to him
and i'm like what do you mean just go up
to him he's
referred to
chris berman keith olbermann
chris berman's a two-ton gorilla who
asks if it's okay to sit down
is what he said
like he's a big
you know
to do in this shop the two-ton gorilla
of espn but he's nice enough to not just
bash people around because he's the
two-ton gorilla he's like may i sit down
please
he's just a sweetheart of a guy
and
so i heard that echoing in my head
when i
walked into
a makeup room shortly after my first few
shows on the air
i was doing the seven o'clock eastern
sports center on a sunday night prior to
chris's
baseball tonight that he was doing
remember chris always emceed this sunday
night he always hosted these sunday
night baseball tonight shows
at any rate
when you walk through the hallways or at
least back in the day
of espn
there would be be these banners espn
banners
that would be hanging
off the top of the pre-fabricated
cubicles that created these
hallways in between the massive
buildings of the massive complex of espn
and there would be on these banners and
these are the banners that you see
hanging over the side of a
of a baseball stadium when espn's
broadcasting from there to let you know
it's an espn broadcast
so
there would be these espn banners hung
on the walls there
with a note from people saying this is
for such and such charity
please sign if you're an on-air talent
and i would look at that and i'd see dan
patrick's autograph and keith
olbermann's autograph and robin roberts
autograph and chris berman's autograph
and so on and so forth and i thought to
myself
you know can i sign it now
i mean at what point
am i
allowed to sign these things should i
feel comfortable signing these things
you know i'm just some 26 year old just
fresh out of nowhere nobody knows who i
am on the air and i'm gonna sign it like
i'm an on-air talent that's making
this piece of memorabilia more valuable
you know i kind of felt self-conscious
about signing these banners
and um so when i strolled into this
makeup room and berman sitting there and
it's just me him and the makeup artist
making him up
i decided
to take my shot since he's the the nice
two-ton gorilla
and i said to him hey chris nice to meet
you um rich eisen goes i know you are
i'm see on tv and just
i enjoying the place how's it going here
and i'm like it's great i'm really
enjoying it but i'm i'm wondering if i
could ask you for a piece of advice go
for it shoot
so i explained it on my
conundrum of these banners asking for
autographs
for a charity auction on
[Music]
a banner
to raise money for charity and the
number of autographs on it would
obviously make it more valuable and i'm
just wondering
when is it
okay for me to sign these banners
literally ask chris brown i i figured
you were the perfect person to ask
having helped create this place
when is it okay for me to sign these
banners and his response was how many
shows have you done
one
at least one and i'm like yeah i've done
a few he goes then [ __ ] it
sign them all
and i'm like okay
and i turned around and i grabbed the
sharpie and i went right down the line
and i signed all the banners because
chris berman gave me his go-ahead and
green light
in only the way that chris could say it
and deliver it and i love that man and
never felt self-conscious about signing
anything with an espn logo on it ever
again
and i'm just thrilled that here i am now
geez wow 25 years later with this
podcast just chit-chatting with the man
who is as great as they come as great in
all time and i could not have
a podcast series on voices of the nfl
without boomer the schwamme the schwamm
chris berman
still to come on just getting started
chris collinsworth is going to be on
this podcast mike tarico is going to be
on this podcast we've already had some
great chats with jim nance and kevin
harlan the voice of monday night
football on westwood one michael strahan
aaron andrews joel bach and al michaels
if you missed any of them please go back
and check out our archives and enjoy
what you hear and of course give us a
five stars rating and
a subscription why don't you
that's it for this episode of just
getting started
you